you just heard destitute D'Souza tell us
about the horrors of these political
prosecutions by the Obama administration
which I asked former AG Mike bkz about a
short while ago judge Mukasey thanks so
much for joining us tonight we just
heard my interview with Dinesh D'Souza
about the horrors of these political
prosecutions what he believes by the
Obama administration and his experience
certainly has some implication I think
for the Russian investigation as we
might look at this unholy alliance of
the FBI director Jim Comey and DOJ
prosecutors what do you think about for
lack of a better term these this runaway
prosecution that a lot of us are
concerned about I think that in the
normal course that sort of case would
have been prosecuted with with with with
with the outcome being a fine it's not
one of Preet Bharara as brighter
chapters that he participated in in
prosecuting this and the way that he did
he's had a couple of other dings and
dents but that was I think of a pretty
substantial one judge Mukasey
Adam Schiff said that the pardon of
dinesh d'souza is basically a
transparent effort by the President to
signal to others that look if you if you
do right by me I'll do right by you it's
further evidence of a corrupt intent on
the president's part further evidence
that he may have violated the law by
obstructing justice in the firing of
Comey but in other efforts as well it
looks a lot like a message to Michael
Cohen who may also be implicated in
exceeding campaign limits with that
stormy Daniels payment and then you have
the further announcement by the
president that he made pardon Martha
Stewart another TV personality he was
convicted of guess what obstruction of
justice and lying to authorities
so he's nothing if not transparent oh
please they've sent the same thing every
time he either issues a pardon or makes
what makes Oh makes a statement that
it's a it's a signal it's a dog whistle
and so on and so forth I think the
prosecution of dinesh d'souza in the way
that it was done
was unjustified I think the prosecution
of Martha Stewart was dubious and so far
as rod Blagojevich I thought the
prosecution of him was entirely
justified now the president simply
commuted his sentence I don't know
whether he should have done that or not
he served six years and that's a that's
a judgment call
he was certainly but certainly not
pardoned let's talk about what John
Brennan has been up to he's now a
commentator on another network and of
course former top Intel official the US
government but he has been on a tear on
president Trump I think the mr. Trump
has demonstrated a paranoia and
insecurity as well as a real concern
about the investigation that is underway
certainly his tweets do not seem like
they're coming from a person of
innocence and confidence my reaction is
ordinarily would be that John Brennan
was director of the CIA maybe should be
told to stick to his day job the trouble
is I think given what we're finding out
about the way he did his day job
including his participation in putting
an informant into the Trump campaign
maybe we're even maybe were better off
with him as as kind of an amateur pundit
I think that he may be projecting his
own views if I may be an amateur
psychiatrist for the moment on on to the
president because he is going to have a
lot to answer for
I believe when all when the entire story
gets told about what the CIA was doing
in connection with the the running of
the investigation and what it was doing
with regard to what had been its
informant and his being put into the the
the Trump campaign we talked about a
little about this on radio this morning
judge but you made a great point and you
asked this question which is why you're
so smart who paid this informant was he
just doing this pro bono this might work
for the Truvia clinton campaign or for
the US government woman what was it who
paid understand his his history was as a
CIA asset being put into an FBI
investigation is very odd you understand
he's these two agencies
number one don't don't share their toys
very well and aren't supposed to the CIA
is supposed to operate in an
outward-looking
foreign directed fashion they're not
supposed to be doing anything in the
United States there's a statute that
restricts that the FBI conducts
intelligence investigations in the
United States and for him to be put into
an essentially an FBI investigation I
kind of like to know how that happened
who coordinated it who paid him and how
that was arranged and what was arranged
Barbara McQuade is a former US attorney
appointed by Barack Obama and she said
the following today I think today's news
about Michael Cohen really shows you
what he expects in an attorney general
his experience with a lawyer is someone
like Michael Cohen a pit bull of Roy
combs someone who will protect him
someone who will be very aggressive in
defending his interests no matter what
being loyal to President Trump as
opposed to loyal to the mission and if
that is his motivation that is a crime
for her to comment on what president
Trump's expectations are in his attorney
general when the Attorney General who
served in the Obama administration Eric
Holder referred to himself as the
president's wingman strikes me as pretty
rich yeah I mean you were Attorney
General I mean talk about the
relationship between a president and the
Attorney General people people making
out this out to be such a crime that
President Trump wanted an attorney
general whose first instinct it was not
to accuse himself now the recusal issue
is something you know we've talked about
before but that has stuck in the
president's craw now if I were the
president I would not be tweeting I wish
I hadn't selected Jeff Sessions I don't
know what he thinks that gets him I
don't I don't think that's particularly
wise to do but nevertheless that's how
he feels he just he thought why am i
pointing at Attorney General if the
first thing you do is recuse yourself
well the circumstances kind of caught up
with Jeff Sessions and with the
president and at the time that Jeff
Sessions recused himself it may be that
he technically didn't have to
because the investigation at that point
was a foreign intelligence investigation
not a criminal investigation but then
due in large measure the things that the
president said and did it became a
criminal investigation and at that point
regulations required that Jeff Sessions
recuse himself now for the president to
suggest that somehow Jeff Sessions
should have had the gift of prophecy and
known that the situation would develop
that way I think it's ridiculous and for
him to start claiming that he should
have appointed somebody else is is is is
inane and it doesn't as you point out it
doesn't serve his interest particularly
when he's got an AG in place in the
person of Jeff Sessions who is pursuing
his agenda and very effectively bringing
ms-13 cases immigration cases concluding
a huge antitrust settlement doing
effectively running the Justice
Department so I think you ought to quit
complaining about that Judge Michael
Mukasey a former attorney general of the
United States thanks so much